on sent une ambiance extrêmement grave
mais les personnes qui sont ici près de
la place maïdan apparaissent extrêmement
soudée et déterminée
à résister à cet ennemi commun à
l'ennemi russe vous savez qu'en principe
les autorités avaient interdit tout
rassemblement toute manifestation ici en
principe chaque année depuis 1991 a lieu
une parade militaire en lieu et place
cette année il ya l'exposition de chars
russes qui ont été détruits ces six
derniers mois et comme vous pouvez le
constater derrière moi malgré
l'interdiction du rassemblement
des centaines de personnes viennent pour
voir ses chars pour se faire
photographier devant dans le silence
c'est une atmosphère extrêmement
silencieuses extrêmement grave nous
avons parlé à plusieurs de ces personnes
pour savoir quelles étaient leurs
sentiments au bout de six mois de guerre
un jeune couple qui vient de kiev et de
boudhha et qui restait ces six derniers
mois qui avaient butch à ils sont
stylistes tous les deux nous ont dit que
il trouvait que finalement tout ça était
absolument sûr et elle est qu' il ne
compte qu ils ne comprenaient pas une
russie s'est pas réalisé comment au 21e
siècle un pays comme la russie pouvait
encore ont agressé un autre et que il
restait leur façon de se montrer
patriotes et solidaire était de rester
en ukraine et de ne pas quitter le pays
plus loin une femme de 70 ans qui est là
sa famille qui est partie ces enfants
qui sont partis à l'étranger elle est
restée et nous a dit qu elle manifestait
enfin elles défilé avec son drapeau
ukrainien et que pour heinz qui était
important c'était de montrer sa
solidarité qu'elle voulait la paix et
quand on lui a demandé mais quel type de
paix vous voulez est-ce que vous
accepteriez la paix si la russie disait
que maintenant elle est l'arrêté ans
avec en gardant les territoires et la
dino absolument pas ce que nous voulons
c'est la victoire et finalement elle
reprend les termes du président hélène
ski qui dit aujourd'hui ce que nous
voulons c'est la victoire et non pas la
paix tout simplement plus tôt ce matin
nous avons rencontré deux militaires qui
nous donne et qui nous ont dit avoir
l'impression que la population dans son
ensemble continuer à les soutenir à
soutenir l'armée ukrainienne ils ne font
absolument aucune prospective pour les
mois à venir mais pense quand même que
ce qui fera la différence dans ce
conflit et dans cette guerre d'usure
ce seront les armes qui vont être ou pas
livré par l'occident virginie vous avez
aussi rencontré des familles qui sont
tout juste revenus de l'étranger des
familles qui avaient fui le cren quel
est leur état d'esprit
alors il faut savoir que un quart de la
population a dû fuir a dû fuir c'est son
son logement et la moitié d'entre eux
sont à l'étranger à la faveur de l'été
et des vacances certaines familles
effectivement sont revenus pour les
retrouvailles vous rappelez quand même
que les hommes n'ont pas pu quitter le
pays donc ce n'est beaucoup de
retrouvailles familiales certaines
personnes âgées aussi sont restés ici et
finalement on peut s'apercevoir que les
sept familles sont extrêmement divisée
nous avons rencontré hier une
psychologue de qui a la cinquantaine qui
a fui au royaume uni elle vient
d'obtenir une proposition de poste à
l'université a décidé de rester là bas
parce que la situation est encore trop
précaire ici en revanche sa fille qui a
une trentaine d'années qui est prof
d'anglais a décidé elle de venir se
réinstaller à kiev malgré les risques
parce que tout simplement elle est
amoureuse elle est tombée amoureuse de
d'un peu de temps avant la guerre qui
l'a demandée en mariage et elle veut
rester elle veut rester ici elle veut
rester ici aussi pour s'occuper de sa
grand mère de 85 ans donc on voit que
c'est des situations extrêmement
partagées mais globalement les familles
qui ont des enfants petit ou en bas âge
préfère repartir dans l'ouest du pays ou
à l'étranger tant que la ctu la
situation n'est pas véritablement
sécurisé